to be released in December this year Tom
Clancy's The Division compromised as the
sequel to The recruited novel released
earlier this year I was fortunate enough
to get my hands on a review copy and
after reading through it twice I'm going
to give my own spoiler-free review
however if you haven't read recruited
and you're planning to I suggest
switching off the video now I won't be
talking about everything that happened
but there will certainly be some parts
that'll cover that could be considered
as spoilers I'll put a link to my review
of recruited in the description
otherwise let's get into it
foreign
[Music]
right off the bat you can tell that
compromise has been written in a way
that doesn't require you to have any
prior experience in the series you can
pick this up as a standalone novel and
comfortably follow what's going on
however in saying that I would fully
recommend reading recruited first as
this really sets the scene with what
happens in compromised and having a
deeper understanding of what these
characters have been through up until
this point
as a quick recap of recruiters located
in Maryland Myra kanhai is a cyber
security expert who previously served in
the U.S Navy when things started getting
bad she rushed over to the enlistment
officers so she could do her part in
helping bring the situation back under
control but when she got there she
realized it was too late
the building was dark all she found was
a man in an officer's uniform slumped
over the disc
he'd clearly taken his own life rather
than succumbed to the virus that was
ravaging the country
it was at this point that Myra knew that
all she could do was to fall back and
write out the situation at hand to do
her best to ensure that she and her
younger brother could survive
they would go on to move around from
building to building District to
District in search of a safe place they
could call home
eventually they would join a community
of survivors called Athena
in time Myers passed in the Navy would
become known a much to her objection to
the idea she was placed in charge of
Athena's security protecting it from the
Scavengers and hostile groups who only
wanted to take advantage of what was
going on
unfortunately Mara's time of hit a
security led her to making some tough
decisions some of these decisions
required action for the survival of the
community but would ultimately lead to
the death of members including her own
brother
this would lead to Athena community
members screaming out and placing the
blame on her for everything that went
wrong
speaking of unwanted distracting noise
does your house sound a little something
like this
have you had to listen to Peppa Pig for
the 400th time this week
the big tummy daddy well maybe you just
want a little bit of me time to enjoy
the latest episode of Love Island well
look no further than the Logitech G Pro
X headset in all seriousness my friends
at Logitech sent me through a pier last
week and so far I'm very impressed with
them they're extremely comfortable and
I'm legitimately hearing more in the way
of in-game background sounds than I've
heard previously plus their
compatibility with the G hug companion
software allows for more customization
options to suit your particular
environment no matter how intrusive it
can be
basically they do a bloody good job of
blocking out the stuff you don't want to
hear and provide an immersive enough
experience to ignore the chaos that is
unfolding around you Logitech also sent
me through a stream cam so on my other
Channel that I have really talked about
yet you'll be able to see my exhausted
three hours of sleep a night face in
full HD and 60 frames per second kids
are great really
but otherwise a big thank you to
Logitech for sponsoring the video and
for helping me keep some of my sanity
anyway where were we right Myra kanhai
collapse of society Athena head of
security responsible for her brother's
death
one day Athena would come under attack
from a large group of hyenas Myra knew
this day could come and had prepared the
community the best she could but the
sheer number of hyenas was just too much
fortunately for Athena there happened to
be some division agents operating in the
area just in time they came to their aid
and repelled the attackers but would
unfortunately lose one of their own in
the battle
after the outbreak the traditional way
of recruiting division agents has long
since passed new recruits are now found
out in the field and thrown into the
deep end
after seeing what Myra had attempted to
do for the settlement the most senior
agent Brenda saw something in her and
would accept her into their cell
Myra Brenda and Leo would continue on
with their original Mission before they
came across Athena to assist the I-10
Fleet of truckies who were doing their
best to provide the much needed supplies
to the settlements on the Eastern
seaboard
the agents would learn of their Northern
counterparts the Romans a vicious Armada
of Raiders and bandits
but while engaging this hostile group
they would also learn of a rogue agent
with the new ranks who had a grudge to
settle with the division
following on from their last mission and
recruited the team have been left
bruised and bettered compromise begins
several months after these events while
their physical wounds have more or less
healed the potential psychological scars
aren't quite so easy to see or manage
after their first major mission and all
of the events that led up to it Myra
kanhai is no longer the green recruit
she once was
he still carries the Survivor guilt that
has plagued her since the loss of her
brother and countless others she has
tried to help
this isn't just a story of how they all
tackle their next mission but how
they'll deal with the emotional damage
that has been inflicted on the team
since each of them were first activated
while their previous success over the
Romans brings hope to the damaged Nation
it isn't long before Myra and uselle are
made aware of a group of environmental
extremists who are dead set on helping
the world repair
their first targets Texan oil refineries
they want to see a world free from
fossil fuels the fuels that are also
helping the Truckee Supply the various
settlements of survivors with food and
supplies
after being dispatched they would also
learn of a new private military company
who were acting as the saviors but also
the overlords of these vulnerable
communities
with very different goals in mind these
new factions are a time bomb waiting to
explode and the agents are caught right
in the middle
sequels can often leave a bitter taste
especially if one really enjoyed the
first in the series but I'm happy to
announce that this certainly isn't the
case with compromised if anything I'm
going to say that this is a step up from
recruited and I'll explain why soon
anyone who watched my review on
recruited or even just looked at the
back cover of the book will know that
I'm a fan of Thomas parrott's writing
style but the expectations on a sequel
are always substantially higher it isn't
enough to be just as good as the
original
compromised story flow is relatively
similar to recruited but it felt a
deeper connection to the facilities the
agents were visiting and staying in the
factions originally felt like that they
were just reskinned versions of what
we've already seen in the division
universe but ended up playing out much
differently than what was expected
the relationships between agents
admittedly didn't feel quite the same as
recruited but some of the other
characters were certainly more memorable
I don't think I would call this a
negative but I definitely missed a
little bit of the Sass and the playful
banter that one character in particular
brought in the first novel
one thing that I felt very early on is
that Thomas seems to be finding his
stride in the division Universe now I
feel like he had a bit of fun with this
one
the twists and turns while still present
and recruited were on another tier with
compromised but the reason I really
enjoyed this is a die-hard fan of the
franchise story is that compromise
wasn't just borrowing the division
setting but that there were a couple of
instances that really tied it together
with the story that we all know and love
from the games
I mean the ending there it's
disappointing that a current or won't
talk about it for a little while because
[ __ ] is starting to get interesting up
in here
sorry April calendar I'm going to be
looking out for other Echoes In the game
from here on
if you're a fan of the division story I
see this much light recruited as a must
read
Thomas does a fantastic job of building
a world that has become an everyday
fight for survival the characters are
well articulated to the point of forming
an emotional bond with them and the
action scenes literally had my heart
rate increase while I attempted to read
at the same Pace I imagine the events
were playing out
both novels complement the universe in a
way that the games couldn't video games
need to appeal to an audience in a
different way so it's often the case
that the story suffers to a certain
extent
these novels really flesh out what it's
like living in this world they also add
a more human feel to the division agents
showing their flaws the stuff they have
to go through the damage they take the
way shd Tech works the depth and
repercussions of the decisions they have
to make on the Fly
I'm going to say that my only complaint
is that I have to wait for the next one
in the series and for the game storyline
to catch up to the novels
you can pre-order compromise now I'll
leave a link in the description I'm
actually really looking forward to this
and we'll be happily adding this to my
collection although I admit I still
haven't pushed myself a physical copy of
recruited yet so I should probably get
onto that now anyway I hope you found
this useful I've certainly enjoyed it
and look forward to eventually being
able to talk about what has been
discovered in Myra's Journey thanks for
watching and I'll catch you in the next
one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you